die freiheit in russland sie schrumpft
oppositionelle werden eingesperrt
eingeschüchtert oder müssen flüchten
medien werden unterdrückt die
meinungsfreiheit schwindet
künstler anwälte menschenrechtler unter
druck wer kritik hat soll schweigen wer
nicht schweigt wird hart bestraft
das freie wort es war einmal wer nicht
in putins konservatives leitbild passt
lebt gefährlich
[Musik]
natalia tisch kewitsch welt ist klein
und eng geworden ihre zurzeit engste
verbündete die katze
[Musik]
wenn ich sie flüchtet jetzt ins andere
zimmer
natalias welt das ist zurzeit ihre
wohnung in moskau an der wand kleine
gelbe zettel die fußfessel wird nicht
steuern steht auf einem
durchhalteparolen sind das vor sechs
monaten schickt ein moskauer gericht
natalia in den hausarrest
das ist meine fußfessel ich habe sie
etwas geschmückt so sieht sie
normalerweise nicht aus eigentlich sind
die dinger schlicht spaß ich hab damit
rumgespielt versuchte das kunst
anzubringen
das gerät überwacht ob ich zu hause bin
dass ich nicht flüchten
so gut wie eingesperrt zu hause
eingeschränkte freiheit nennt man das in
russland natalya hatte berichtet für
boxer ein studentenmagazin über ein
thema das der staat nicht sehen und
nicht hören wollte
man hatte sich über uns beschwert
darüber dass wir ein video über die
proteste auf den straßen veröffentlicht
haben und dass wir berichteten dass die
studenten die an den demos teilnahmen
von ihren unis sich eingeschüchtert
wurden in diesem video haben wir die
leute dazu aufgerufen keine angst zu
haben
natalya klärte studentinnen und
studenten über ihre rechte auf dass man
für die teilnahme an protesten nicht
exmatrikuliert werden dürfe auf druck
der behörden lösch doxa das betreffende
video angeklagt werden natalia und drei
andere trotzdem der vorwurf an stiftung
minderjähriger zu illegalem handeln bis
zum prozess darf sie nur aus der wohnung
wenn sie sich bei ihren polizeibeamten
an und ab meldet für zwei stunden am tag
ihre fußfessel funkt permanent eine
basisstation in der wohnung an
das ding sieht aus wie ein telefon aus
sowjetzeiten
ich habe es in einen pulli eingeschlagen
nicht damit es warm bleibt sondern als
schalldämmung ich denke wo ein telefon
ist hört auch jemand mit
so schützen wir uns vor mit höherer
kreativität ist gefragt im umgang mit
der harten gangart des russischen
staates
heute ist die hochzeit der politischen
gefangenen und boxer redakteurin natalie
tischkicker bilder aus dem juni natalia
heiratet ihren balram öffentlich in
moskau und auf youtube quasi
[Musik]
die hochzeit heute ist notwendig weil
wir kommende woche ein urteil erwarten
das könnte noch längeren hausarrest für
mich bedeuten genau deshalb war es
wichtig bei daran jetzt um seine hand zu
bitten
vielleicht bekomme ich eine vorladung
zum verhör bislang konnte ich mich nicht
auf die verfassung berufen aber in
zukunft kann ich die aussage verweigert
wenn der staat auf angriff schaltet
bleibt nur nach kleinen fluchten zu
suchen
[Musik]
wenn das auto
wer verstehen will warum es so kam muss
zurückblicken
januar dieses jahres tage des aufruhrs
rufe nach freiheit
hunderttausendfach im ganzen land von
sankt petersburg über moskau bis nach
jakutsk sind sie auf der straße
nein
es ist sehr laut hier an der
theaterstraße
alexej post eyof ist mittendrin der
journalist berichtet für den
unabhängigen internet sender durch zeigt
wie die menschen damals freiheit für
navalny rufen die leute fordern die
freilassung von alexander weiß sie
fordern dass er medizinische hilfe
bekommt und von ärzten besucht werden
darf
aber es geht in diesen tagen um mehr als
um den kreml kritiker der eine
vergiftung überlebte zurückkam und
sofort verhaftet wurde die menschen
rufen nach freiheit
auch für sich
mit brutaler härte schlagen polizisten
die demos nieder tausende von menschen
werden verhaftet wer nicht schweigt wird
bestraft wer
kritisch berichtet gerät schnell unter
druck am tag nach seiner live reportage
steht die polizei morgens bei alexej vor
der tür auf dem revier muss er sich zwei
stunden lang für seine arbeit
rechtfertigen
im spätsommer dann der nächste schlag
der sender für den alex horst eyof
arbeitet steht auf der schwarzen liste
des
justizministeriums das dorf zum
ausländischen agenten erklärt wurde habe
ich im urlaub erfahren quasi am strand
einen tag lang hat mir das echt den
urlaub verdorben
alles was dort sendet muss als produkt
eines ausländischen agenten
gekennzeichnet werden einnahmen und
ausgaben seien sie auch noch so klein
müssen dokumentiert werden alle
veröffentlichungen jeder brief tweet
muss einen vorgeschriebenen begleittext
haben ansonsten drohen hohe geldstrafen
werbekunden springen ab wer dort ein
interview gibt oder für den sender
arbeitet läuft gefahr ebenfalls als
ausländischer agent gebrandmarkt zu
werden
es gab fälle in denen freie mitarbeiter
aus einer region russlands und plötzlich
sagten ihr seid ausländische agenten wir
haben angst mit euch zu arbeiten
wir wollen nicht mehr mit euch film aber
insgesamt naja zumindest werden wir auf
der straße noch nicht mit tomaten
beworfen
unsere eltern haben vermutlich mehr
angst als wir
sie hat dort gegründet senderchefin
datei es in der jever ist kummer gewohnt
als letzter unabhängiger sender
russlands wurde dort schon früher
attackiert aus dem kabelnetz verband
sendet dort nur noch online und erreicht
trotzdem ein millionenpublikum im
schnitt 2 millionen aufrufe jeden tag
jetzt wächst der druck auf kreml
unabhängige medien das regime hat neue
gesetze erfunden bestehende verschärft
und die sind eine echte gefahr dass
dieser status ausländischer agent ist
natürlich ein damoklesschwert
weil für jeden verstoß enorme strafen
einige wenige können uns schon vor
gericht bringen wir fragen uns was
bezwecken die da oben eigentlich wenn
sie uns vernichten wollen dann ist das
mit diesem neuen gesetz und diesen
status sicher möglich
das deutsche team will weitermachen
unbedingt andere auch wieder andere aber
haben russland verlassen um der
verfolgung zu entgehen nicht nur
kritische journalistinnen und
journalisten
auch für mitglieder der lgbt kyu
gemeinschaft wird die freiheit immer
kleiner wir fliegen nach spanien
barcelona 3000 kilometer von moskau
entfernt die weltoffene metropole lässt
viel raum zur persönlichen entfaltung
raum den es in russland nicht gibt
hierhin sind die 49-jährige lgbt kyu
aktivistin yuma und ihre crew ihre
familie geflüchtet
es ist sehr schwer das den menschen zu
erklären die noch nie in so einer
situation waren in der wir gelebt haben
mein ganzes leben war ich immer in so
einer verteidigungsposition eine
ständige verteidigungsposition überall
in meiner familie mit den eltern im
kindergarten in der schule in der
universität und auf der straße
in barcelona fühlen sie sich sicher frei
aber die familie ist traumatisiert vom
spießrutenlauf von den anfeindungen mord
und vergewaltigung drohungen die sie in
russland erlebten letzter ausweg flucht
als ich in russland war da gibt es
natürlich ein sehr merkwürdiges
verhältnis mit ihm und natürlich werden
wir da einfach nicht als normale
menschen gesehen
eine krankenschwester fragte mich was
ich in meiner freizeit mache und sie war
sehr überrascht als ich sagte dass ich
mich mit aller liebe tier echten
beschäftige worauf sie die frage stellte
warum du bist du hübsch
im juni hatte die russische
biosupermarktkette focus wilde eine
werbekampagne gestartet titel rezepte
des familienglücks
auch immer ihre beiden töchter und die
partnerin ihrer ältesten machten mit
dann begann der höllenritt die werbung
ein frontalangriff auf das konservativ
geprägte familienbild in russland es
folgte ein shitstorm die supermarktkette
zieht die kampagne zurück entschuldigt
sich bei aufgebrachten kundinnen und
kunden
yuma und ihre familie stehen plötzlich
schutzlos am öffentlichen moral pranger
alles wurde offenkundig durch trolle
gepusht
dann waren wir sehr stark verängstigt
durch die harten und brutalen
botschaften und drohungen und dadurch
dass man unsere adresse veröffentlicht
hatte
man drohte uns dass man so ist nach
hause kommt und uns umbringen wird
unterstützt wird die familie in spanien
vom roten kreuz sie haben eine kleine
wohnung am stadtrand der antrag auf asyl
läuft eine rückkehr in die heimat
derzeit unmöglich
ich liebe russland und ich spüre eine
sehr große verbindung mit russland
natürlich würde ich gern zu erkennen
aber nicht unter dem gegenwärtigen
regime
der blick nach vorne fällt noch schwer
yuma fühlt sagt sie dass sie durch ihre
flucht andere menschen in russland im
stich gelassen hat es gibt noch viele
die dringend hilfe brauchen sagt jammer
denn die sehnsucht nach einem offenen
liberalen leben hat in russland mächtige
gegner vor allem wenn es um die sexuelle
selbstbestimmung geht
diese leute sind sehr aggressiv sie sind
überhaupt nicht schwach sie machen sehr
aggressive propaganda die sie überall
sehen können sie sagen unseren kindern
ihr müsst wie wir sein ich glaube das
hat medizinische gründe und nicht nur
ich glaube dass ich kenne viele ärzte
die das auch so sehen ich möchte dass
meine kinder überhaupt nicht darüber
nachdenken
konstantin malafejew milliardär oligarch
mit besten treten nach ganz oben
die eu und die usa haben ihn mit
sanktionen belegt der vorwurf er
unterstütze separatisten in der ost
ukraine in seinem eigenen fernsehsender
sitzt er am selben tisch mit alexander
borodin der war mal regierungschef der
international nicht anerkannten
volksrepublik daniels
malafejew nutzt sein geld und seinen
sender um seine nachrichten in die welt
zu tragen und die klingen so
seit dieser zeit sei diesen liberale
90er jahren gibt es einen angriff auf
die traditionellen familienwerte und
dieser angriff setzt sich bis heute fort
malafejew glaubt an gott in seinem büro
in moskau ist das nicht zu übersehen er
ist vorkämpfer einer bewegung die
russland prägen will durch ein erz
konservatives alles einvernehmen des
christentum als in sankt petersburg ein
nachfahre des letzten russischen zaren
heiratet gehört oligarch malafejew zum
innersten kreis ein russisches großreich
wie es früher einmal war das ist seine
welt
ja ich denke das wird passieren früher
oder später weil wir nicht getrennt
voneinander leben könne otto von
bismarck abgesagt russland wird immer
nach einheit streben weil der orthodoxe
glaube die russen 1
und wissen sie wir stammen alle aus kiel
das ist unsere mutter statt wir können
niemals glauben dass kiew das dass die
hauptstadt eines anderen landes ist
männer wie malafejew sind mächtig weil
sie vom kreml protegiert werden weil sie
mit geld und netzwerken realpolitik
betreiben
durch sie bleibt für freie gedanken
zunehmend weniger platz zensur für
künstler auftrittsverbote für rapper und
andere musiker freigeister
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der letzte tag im paradies heißt dieser
song die band no guts velo übersetzt
warten krampf ihr sänger maxim potofski
[Musik]
ein einziger abgesang auf das freie
leben in russland
wir fahren zu seiner datscha einige
stunden westlich von moskau auch für
künstler ist russland längst kein
paradies mehr immer mehr themen sind zur
verbotenen frucht geworden wer diese
früchte pflückt muss mit harten
konsequenzen rechnen
ich bin ein zeuge und was ich gerade
sehr in den vergangenen paar monaten das
ist die dramatischste
bedeutendste zeit in unserer jüngeren
geschichte
weil es so still geworden ist wir sind
fertig
es tut mir leid wir sind total im arsch
maxime prograf ski hat selbst erfahren
wie der staat künstlern die luft
abschnürt
[Musik]
ich erinnere mich an uns in freiheit
singt er mit
seiner band hatte er sich für die
freilassung von alexei navalny stark
gemacht bilder von den demos gepostet
wir haben ein paar post abgesetzt
besonders einen im januar über navalny
und dann wurde unsere tour verboten
erstmal haben wir sie nach hinten
verschoben dann haben wir sie abgesagt
weil der veranstalter sich wie ein
verrückter verhalten hat bislang haben
sie mich noch nicht verhaftet aber wer
weiß was noch kommen
bukowski lebt seit 2009 10 teilweise in
den usa sein herz aber gehört russland
dieses jahr war für ihn traumatisch
wir haben hier eine demokratie zumindest
nennen wir es so aber fakt ist hier gab
es nie demokratie keiner unserer
staatschefs ist jemals auf
demokratischem wege an die macht
gekommen
es sind diese beobachtungen die sie in
ihren songs verarbeiten dieser hier
heißt am arsch mal zehn bis 20 jahre
unter putin mit viel wut
baseballschläger und e gitarren
gibt es eine chance in russland sagen
wir die hoffnung stirbt zuletzt und ich
sage ja die hoffnung stirbt zuletzt aber
früher oder später stirbt sie alles und
jeder ist irgendwann am ende und stirbt
demokratie scheint in weiter ferne
militärische stärke patriotismus auf
diese werte lenkt russlands führung dem
blick sie sollen die zukunft des landes
bestimmen
beschützen wollen diese jugendlichen das
andenken an den großen vaterländischen
krieg wie der zweite weltkrieg hier
heißt
patriotische jugendclubs aus ganz
russland sind zusammengekommen für einen
wettbewerb in heimat liebe
[Musik]
es gibt hier kein einzelschicksal alles
schicksale sind zu einem einzigen
verschmolzen und dem ewigen feuer sieht
man einen aufgeflammten panzer brennende
russische hütten brennen des moments und
den brennenden reichstag das brennende
herz eines eidgenossen
der schrecken der kriegsjahre findet
sich in den aufführungen wieder das
millionenfache leid dass der kampf gegen
nazi-deutschland der sowjetunion
abverlangte
auf das derzeit mit seinem dreckigen
stiefel nicht den weizen auf den feldern
vertreter und keine granaten detonieren
dafür sind wir auch sehr
wohnlich kalaschnikows in kinderhänden
wir sind von einem beispiellosen kampf
einem einzigartigen schicksal geprägt
wir alle sind leningrader
vitali beljajew und seine jungs sind aus
der nähe von sankt petersburg angereist
super der das gemacht ihrem prachtkerl
mein mikrofon lässt sich die ganze zeit
nicht anschalten
super wirklich
doch dieser auftritt war nur die erste
disziplin am nächsten tag steht
marschieren auf dem wettkampfplan auf
dem platz der ehre in der
zentralrussischen kleinstadt wehr geht
es an diesem sonntag um disziplin
konzentration
jugend im gleichschritt
eineinhalb monate haben die jungs von
patrioten club der schuss dafür
trainiert
wir müssen uns der geschichte für unsere
große und urgroßväter für uns gekämpft
haben deswegen bin ich in diesem verein
und möchte das auch bekannter machen
damit man sich noch jahrhunderte lang an
diesen krieg erinnert und damit sich
solche kriege nicht wiederholen
die teilnahme in einem patriotischen
jugendclub öffnet in russland türen zur
besseren hochschulen militärakademien
einer glänzenden zukunft im system
der schirmherr des wettbewerbs anatoli
dozou hat für die sowjets in afghanistan
gekämpft für russland in tschetschenien
das tri team aus deutschland ist ihm
nicht ganz geheuer
einige dürfen die hier sein habt ihr
eine genehmigung fragen zu stellen ihr
kommt doch aus einem anderen land ja
aber wir sind akkreditiert
ihr habt eine akkreditierung natürlich
wir wollen dass die jugend die
traditionen der familie kennt und die
alten verehrt und dies muss man tun
damit es nicht so etwas wie navalny gibt
der einen schlachtruf ausgibt wen nimmt
er zu sich als helfer nun kinder von der
straße
alle haben jetzt computer alle haben
smartphones ich stehe hier und habe ein
smartphone am herzen früher war da das
parteibuch jetzt ist dein smartphone
alexander optik hat beides parteibuch
und smartphone der geschichtslehrer ist
mitglied der oppositionellen jabloko
partei und er produziert youtube videos
in denen kritisiert alexander die
regierung von wladimir putin die kreml
politstrategen versuchen den
patriotismus für ihre zwecke zu nutzen
die heimat lieber den stolz auf die
erfolge in wissenschaft und kultur
versuchen sie gegen die treue zu
wladimir putin dem fsb und rost war ihr
einzutauschen die russische geschichte
soll so verstanden werden dass es dem
aktuellen regime nutzt nicht alle
historischen fakten passender ins bild
der sieg im großen vaterländischen krieg
wird mythologisierung es gibt
mittlerweile neue gesetze wie zum
beispiel dass man die nazis nicht mit
stalin vergleichen darf wenn ich sage am
ersten september hat deutschland polen
attackiert und am 17 september kamen die
sowjetischen truppen nach polen dann
habe ich schon gegen das gesetz
verstoßen man darf das so nicht sagen
dabei habe ich nur fakten genannt
2020 noch zum lehrer des jahres seine
heimatstadt gekürt hat alexanders kreml
kritische haltung in mittlerweile den
job gekostet nachdem der 32 jährige im
januar videos von protesten ins netz
gestellt hatte wurde er von seiner
schule zur kündigung gedrängt
bewaffnete durchsuchten die wohnung
seiner mutter wo auch alexander lebt
fünf tage saß er in ordnungshaft
das sind keine rechtsschutzorgane
sondern organe zum schutz der
herrschenden sie beschützen nicht das
recht sondern die macht habe
das historische heldentum des volkes
wurde 2020 in der verfassung
festgeschrieben
wissenschaftliche diskussionen über
zweifelhafte entscheidungen der
sowjetführung damit unterbunden
schulbücher werden umgeschrieben lehrer
unter druck gesetzt alexander führt
unser team zu einem denkmal es erinnert
an die opfer politischer verfolgung in
der sowjetunion
das auch derzeit menschen aufgrund
politischer motive einsätzen habe ich
selbst zu spüren bekommen und als bei
mir die durchsuchung erfolgte die
ausschließlich politisch motiviert war
sie durchsuchen und die entlassung all
dies geschah aufgrund politischer motive
sergej ist zurück vom treffen der
patriotischen jugendclubs und wer zu
hause in einem dorf bei sankt petersburg
wartet sein zweites großes hobby das
quad
er hat es erst vor wenigen wochen zum
geburtstag geschenkt bekommen
200 kubikzentimeter der motor die
höchstgeschwindigkeit 60
stundenkilometer
der berufswunsch des zwölfjährigen
automechaniker in space familie ist die
geschichte der zweite weltkrieg kein
abstraktes schulfach sondern persönliche
erinnerung heimat liebe bedeutet für sie
auch die gegenwart nicht zu kritisch zu
sehen wie die kinder sollen in dem
verständnis groß werden dass es weitaus
schlechter sein könnte und dass wir alle
in frieden und in gesundheit leben gott
sei dank ist alles gut dank der menschen
die unsere heimat verteidigt haben schon
über russlands heutigen kurs in der
außenpolitik die verstrickung in
verschiedene kriege und konflikte möchte
die familie lieber nicht sprechen
wir bemühen uns dem keine aufmerksamkeit
zu schenken und unsere eigenen ziele zu
erreichen in erster linie in der
erziehung aber das was auf dem
politischen gebiet passiert dem schenken
wir nicht zu viel aufmerksamkeit
an den wochenenden fahren sergej und die
anderen von patrioten club der schuss
oft in den wald trainieren
wenn dann ein krieg anfängt werde ich es
nicht so schwer haben
denkst du dass ein krieg beginnen wird
vielleicht dann ist aber direkt ein
atomkrieg wird
deswegen
du möchtest darauf vorbereitet sein
naja zwischen 20 und 30 kinder kommen zu
den veranstaltungen des vereins die
jüngsten sind fünf jahre alt
teamgeist disziplin mut und stärke will
vitali bhf seinen schützlingen
vermitteln
nach dem graben laufen wir darüber ich
gebe jedem eine patrone der eine waffe
hat und derjenige gibt einen schuss ab
er steckt die patrone ins magazin hakt
es ein und feuert anschluss ab
verstanden
vitali bay es war selbst beim militär
der große vaterländische krieg ist sein
lebensthema das wissen über ausdauer und
leidensfähigkeit ihrer vorfahren soll
die kinder anspornen
dass der stalinismus auch repression
tote und verfolgung für millionen
sowjetbürger bedeutete spielt in den
geschichtsstunden des patrioten clubs
keine große rolle
jedes land hatte mal dunkle zeiten und
über diese dunkle vergangenheit mögen
nicht alle laut sprechen ja es ist teil
unserer geschichte und wir müssen es
wissen ich glaube wenn damals bestimmte
maßnahmen ergriffen und eine bestimmte
politik verfolgt wurde war es vielleicht
durch diese zeiten bedingt vielleicht
sollte es dann so sein
[Musik]
wir sind nachkommen des terrors singt
maxime potofski von pillen und lügen
betäubt
der musiker sieht sein land auf einem
düsteren pfad
[Musik]
wir stehen nicht still nicht nur im
vergleich zur welt sondern im vergleich
mit uns selbst bewegen wir uns rückwärts
ich kann auch erklären warum wir dürfen
jetzt nicht mal mehr das machen was noch
vor einem oder zwei jahren erlaubt war
nicht mal friedliche proteste sind noch
erlaubt
selbst das ist in russland dieser tage
schon gewagt natalia und die drei
anderen angeklagten redakteurinnen und
redakteure von boxer haben einen termin
beim staatlichen ermittlungskomitee
eine seltene gelegenheit sie außerhalb
des hausarrestes zu treffen
russland sieht eine konservative wende
verschiedenste initiativen werden
deswegen unterdrückt
[Musik]
die jungen leute protestieren der geht
die jugend ist unzufrieden über das was
hier passiert die antwort darauf sind
repressionen
eine friedliche versammlung wie diese
könnten die behörden jederzeit als
unerlaubten protest werten mit
strafrechtlichen konsequenzen für alle
teilnehmenden
das vorgehen der polizei heute bleibt es
höflich
bürger versperren sie den passanten
nicht den weg
der angriff auf die freiheit verändert
russland offene kritik erfordert viel
mut den haben nur noch wenige
diejenigen die wir getroffen haben sind
fest entschlossen den kampf für eine
freie zukunft in russland nicht
aufzugeben